قالها بوتين يوما
إذا كان القتال أمراً لا مفر منه،
فعليك أن تضرب أولاً".
"وما الحاجة بنا إلى عالم ليس به روسيا".
بوتين الذي أمر القوات النووية الاستراتيجية
بالاستعداد للحرب!
فماذا لو نشبت حرب عالمية ثالثة؟
كيف سيكون الموقف العربي؟
ومع من سيكون العرب؟
أو بالأحرى كيف سيكون الوضع الاقتصادي العربي
قبل كل شيء؟ ...
الحرب التي لن تربحها الدول العربية
ولن تخسرها في الوقت ذاته لكنها بالتأكيد
ستنخرط فيها رغما عنها،
فهل تكون هذه فرصة للعرب
"لإدماج قضاياهم في المزاج العالمي؟"،
دول الخليج في منأى عن الحرب
لكنها ليست في منأى عن الأزمة،
فلماذا قد تتأثر دول الخليج بتداعيات الأزمة الأوكرانية؟
وما المخاوف الخليجية المباشرة من اندلاع الحرب؟
ولماذا تجد دول الخليج نفسها في قلب التوترات
الدولية بين روسيا والغرب؟
هيمنت الحرب الروسية في أوكرانيا
على أجندة أعمال قادة دول العالم..
ومن بينها الدول العربية ولا سيما دول الخليج
المصدرة للنفط.
(جمهورية مصر العربية)
مؤخرا منعت روسيا السياحة عن الجميع
ما عدا جمهورية مصر فما الذي يعينه هذا؟
بينما الجانب المصري يمسك العصا من الوسط
واقفا على الحياد جراء الأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية،
وترفض مصر الضغوط الأمريكية الغربية لإدانة
روسيا في حربها ضد أوكرانيا..
وبينما تقول التقارير بتوطيد العلاقات بين مصر
التي تعتبر من أقوى الدول عربيا وعالميا
وبين روسيا، مقابل شك في علاقاتها
مع الجانب الأمريكي...
..
(الجزائر بلد المليون شهيد)
...
الجزائر أكبر دولة عربية مساحةً،
والتي قدمت مليون شهيد بسبب الغزو الأوروبي،
هل تكون اليوم المنقذ لأوروبا بتعويضهم عن غاز روسيا؟
دفعت الأزمة الأوكرانية إلى طرح العديد من التساؤلات،
إن كانت الجزائر ستلعب دور البديل لغاز روسيا
إن تأزم الوضع وقطعت الأخيرة الإمدادات
عن القارة الأوروبية؟،
في ظل علاقات جيدة بين أبناء الصحراء وموسكو؟
(علاقات متينة بين الجزائر وموسكو)
تتميز العلاقات الجزائرية الروسية بكونها متينة
منذ استقلال الجزائر عام 1962،
في شقيها الدبلوماسي والعسكري.
وتعتبر موسكو أول ممون للجزائر بالأسلحة،
وحسب مراقبين فإن مشترياتها بلغت مليارات الدولارات
على مدار السنوات الماضية، منها طائرات
"سوخوي" و "ميغ" وأخرى لنقل الجند ومروحيات
ودبابات إضافة إلى 6 غواصات، وأنظمة دفاع جوية متطورة.
ووقعت الجزائر وروسيا في 2001،
اتفاقية شراكة استراتيجية للتعاون في عدد من المجالات،
على غرار القطاع العسكري والتجاري والطاقة.
كما ترتبط سوناطراك الجزائرية للمحروقات
بعلاقات وطيدة مع شركات طاقة روسية
على غرار غاز بروم و"لوك أويل" وشركات أخرى.
(العراق وأفغانستان خير دليل)
يرى العرب الكوارث التي أنتجتها أمريكا
خلال تدخلها في العراق، ولن ينسى العرب
أكثر من مليون قتيل عراقي جراء الغزو الأمريكي،
وأما في أفغانستان فعاثت أمريكا في الأرض فسادا،
وخرجت بعد عشرين عاما من العبث،
حتى أن الشعب الأفغاني صار يبيع الكلى
لمواجهة الفقر، وانخفض سعر الكلية،
التي تراوحت ذات يوم من 3500 دولار
إلى 4000 دولار، إلى أقل من 1500 دولار
منذ أن سيطرت طالبان على السلطة".
(هذه الأدلة تجعل العرب يفكرون ألف مرة
قبل التحالف مع أمريكا مرة أخرى)
(اليمن الجريح)
أعلنت جماعة أنصار الله الحوثية التي تسيطر
على العاصمة اليمنية صنعاء،
رسميا أنها مع حق روسيا في الحفاظ على أمنها،
وأن الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا ليس إلا شأنا روسيا
داخليا لا يخص الغرب وأمريكا،،
بينما يعاني الشعب اليمني من حرب منذ سنوات
تقودها دول الخليج ضد اليمنيين ما جعل اليمن
الدولة الأشد فقرا في العالم في الوقت الحالي...
هل تقف الإمارات مع الأقوى؟
ظلت دولة الإمارات حليفا استراتيجيا لأمريكا
في المنطقة، حتى أنها كانت من أوائل الدول
المطبعة مع إسرائيل،، وهنا همست تل أبيب
في أذن أمراء الإمارات أن يعلنوا رفضهم
للغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا، لكن هنا كانت المفاجأة.
إذ أعلنت الإمارات دعم القرار الروسي دون سابق إنذار...
(خارطة التحالفات تتبلور في الخليج العربي)
وأكد ولي عهد أبو ظبي محمد بن زايد “
حق روسيا في الدفاع عن أمنها القومي”،
وفق بيان للخارجية الروسية.
لعقود من الزمن، سارت القوتان القويتان في الخليج،
الإمارات والسعودية، على إيقاع الولايات المتحدة،
الإمارات تركت حليفها الأمريكي خوفا ورعبا من روسيا،
فعندما تعلّق الأمر بالتصويت، في مجلس الأمن الدولي،
تجاهلت الإمارات مناشدات واشنطن
وانضمت بدلا من ذلك إلى الصين والهند
في الامتناع عن التصويت، "ما أبرز إحباط أبو ظبي
من السياسات الأمريكية".
أما السعودية إحدى أكبر الدول العالمية تصديرا للنفط
إن لم تكن الأكبر، الحليف الغني لأمريكا
في الدول العربية، كان التحالف الأمريكي  السعودي
يمضي وفق قاعدة(النفط مقابل الأمان والحماية)..
وليست السعودية فقط بل الكثير من الدول العربية
تدفع للأمريكان مقابل الحماية،
وأي حماية يا سادة!
(يقول المصريون: حاميها حراميها)
لكن السعودية رفضت طلبا أمريكيا برفع إنتاج النفط
لضرب نفط روسيا، وهي تعلم أن أي مشاركة
في الضغط على روسيا قد تجبر الرياض
على مواجهة مباشرة مع موسكو،
وأعلن مجلس الوزراء السعودي التزامه باتفاق
(أوبك بلس) مع روسيا، رغم الضغوط المتزايدة
على المملكة لزيادة الإنتاج.
من جهتها قطر دعت إلى ضبط النفس
والجلوس على طاولة المفاوضات،
لكن الجانب القطري أيضا لن يرغب بمواجهة
مباشرة مع روسيا، وذلك بعد ضغط أمريكي غربي
على أن تغطي قطر واردات أوروبا من الغاز،
مما يعني أن تترك قطر الصين المستورد الرئيسي لغازها،
والصين هي أبرز حلفاء روسيا، وكما أن قطر
لن تود عداء روسيا فهي كذلك لا ترغب
بعداء الصين وهي الدول التي يتوقع
أن تقود العالم بعد الأزمة الحالية...
(القواعد العسكرية)
بناء قواعد عسكرية أجنبية
في العديد من دول المنطقة العربية،
تركز في معظمها على الدول ذات المواقع الاستراتيجية
المهمة جيوسياسية إما لامتلاكها ثروات طبيعية
كالنفط والغاز، أو لموقعها الجغرافي الهام
في طرق الملاحة العالمية، ويعتبر التواجد الأمريكي
هو الأكبر في المنطقة العربية،
ويضم أكثر من 60 ألف جندي في بلدان عربية
مختلفة، مع تواجد فرنسي وبريطاني،
وتواجد روسي مركز في سوريا،
أو تواجد تركي ناشئ يحاول الموازنة
مع باقي القواعد العسكرية الأجنبية.
ومع أن القواعد العسكرية الأمريكية
متواجدة في دول الخليج ومعظم الدول العربية،
بينما روسيا لديها قاعدة عسكرية في سوريا،
إلا أن خوف العرب من عداء روسيا أكثر من خوفهم
من عداء الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية!!
( وبذلك فقد عرفنا لماذة وقف العرب مع الجانب
الأمريكي سابقا ولماذا يتركونه حاليا،
بينما يسعى الجميع لإرضاء موسكو.
فالجميع يقف مع المنتصر والمنتصر هو الأقوى،
والأزمة الحالية تظهر أن ما هي إلا أيام قليلة
وتسيطر موسكو على كييف؟)
تقول التقارير أن "الروس أصبحوا شركاء استراتيجيين
مع دول الخليج والمنطقة، خاصة
في بعض الملفات السياسية مثل ملفات سوريا
واليمن وليبيا، وكذلك في بعض الملفات الدبلوماسية،
إضافة إلى الملفات الخاصة بالتسليح،
وكذلك العلاقات التجارية التي شهدت تقدماً
خلال السنوات الأخيرة، وكل ذلك جعل روسيا
تصبح لاعباً مهماً تحتاج دول الخليج إلى وجوده
لتهدئة أوضاع المنطقة".
بينما تستورد الدول العربية قمحها
من روسيا أو من أوكرانيا التي باتت قريبة
من الدخول تحت سلطة موسكو .
فدول كالجزائر ومصر وليبيا وتونس واليمن
والعراق وسوريا ولبنان، يبدو أنها في طرف
روسيا في الأزمة الحالية، لتأمين غذائها،
أو لإيصال قضاياهم ومظاليمهم إلى المزاج الغربي،
فيما دول الخليج لا ترغب بعدو كروسيا وحلفائها
الصين وكوريا الشمالية،
وقد أخذت دول الخليج عبرة من تحالفها
مع أمريكا طيلة الفترة السابقة،
وهم لا يريدون تكرار أخطاء الماضي،
ولكن يبقى أن نقول أن معظم الحروب الحالية
هي سياسية بالدرجة الأولى.
وفي السياسة لا صديق دائم ولا عدو دائم،،
وكما يقولها المصريون
(المصالح تتصالح ي عم)...